For thousands of years, Mohave tribes dotted
the land in and around what is now the modern-day
city of Las Vegas.
Sometime in the 1770s, Spanish missionary
Francisco Gracias became the first foreigner
to encounter the tribes.
As he detailed in his travel notes, their
meeting was quite friendly.
In 1826, the first English-speaking explorer,
Jedediah Smith, came upon this land and the
tribes.
In a letter he wrote to General William Clark,
the Superintendent of Indian Affairs for the
US, he described his peaceful encounter,
After traveling 300 miles in that direction
through a country somewhat fertile, in which
there was a great many Indians, mostly naked
and destitute of arms, with the exception
of a few bows and arrows and what is very
singular amongst Indians, they cut their hair
to the length of three inches; they proved
to be friendly; their manner of living is
on fish, roots, acorns and grass.
Only three years later, the Mexican trader
Antonio Armijo was traveling with his company
through the area (though a bit to the north)
to forge a trade route from New Mexico to
Los Angeles.
They were thrilled to find the valley to be
somewhat fertile and wet, unlike most of their
desert travels.
So, they named it “Las Vegas,” meaning
“fertile plains.”
The great explorer John Fremont, appointed
by President John Tyler, led a company of
surveyors and scouts through the valley and
beyond in 1844.
He went on to publish his report that ended
up being the guide for settlers in years to
come, entitled “Report of the Exploring
Expedition to the Rocky Mountains 1842 to
Oregon and Northern California in 1843-44.”
In it, he describes “gushing springs”
that were great to swim in.
Within ten years, the Las Vegas Valley had
been settled by a variety of explorers, settlers,
traders, and missionaries.
In 1854, the US Congress commissioned it be
a regular stop on the monthly mail service
route between Salt Lake City and Los Angeles
while appropriating $25,000 (about $638,000
today) for military and mail roads.
Among the missionaries settling down in Vegas
were Mormons.
In fact, Brigham Young in spring 1855 called
for thirty men to make their permanent home
in the Las Vegas Valley with the assignment
to “build a fort there to protect immigrants
and the United States mail from Indians.”
For the next fifty years, settlements in the
Las Vegas Valley continued as not much more
than train stops, sporadic mining towns, and
trading posts.
According to Robert McCracken’s book “Las
Vegas: The Great American Playground,” May
15, 1905 was when all that changed and Las
Vegas at least began to resemble the town
we now know today.
On that day, three thousand speculators arrived
mostly from LA and Salt Lake City and were
given a chance to bid on lots of land along
the railroad.
The man who initiated this owned the land
near the railroad and figured to make a tidy
profit from the sales.
This man was US Senator William Andrews Clark,
whom the county that Las Vegas currently resides
in is named after – Clark County.
Directly thereafter, businesses and establishments
that catered to the railway traveler and worker
were built.
Downtown Las Vegas was born.
Completely counter to modern Vegas, it was
technically a “temperance town” during
its early years, meaning that “no liquor
clauses” were written into the deeds of
the lots.
But there were exceptions.
Many of them.
Drug stores, doctor offices, and restaurants
that served food were all allowed to sell
alcohol.
Additionally, after much push back, establishments
in Block 16 and Block 17, between first and
third street on Ogden and Stewart Streets,
were given the green light to serve.
This became known as the “red-light district”
of old Las Vegas.
Bars, saloons, hotels, and brothels populated
the area with the Arizona Club being the biggest
of them all.
Despite this, in 1910, gambling was officially
made illegal.
At least in theory.
For the rest of the country, the Eighteenth
Amendment was ratified in January 1919 and
went into effect the following January.
Prohibition was official in the United States.
Las Vegas, according McCracken’s book, “resisted
compliance with the national laws to the best
of its abilities.”
City officials would let business owners know
when they would be visited by federal agents
far in advance.
Arrests were few and far between.
Fines were more frequent, but even those were
quite nominal, mostly as a punishment for
not being discreet enough.
Although many big cities had speakeasies and
a prosperous bootlegging industry, Las Vegas
was nearly lawless in the matter.
Along with prostitution being legal at this
point, it was around this time that Las Vegas
earned its nickname “Sin City.”
The Twenty First Amendment went into law in
December 1931 and Prohibition was officially
repealed across the country.
But it was actually a completely different
kind of government intervention that caused
the population of Las Vegas to boom.
Construction began on the Boulder Dam (later
called Hoover Dam) in 1931, fifty miles from
Vegas.
As thousands upon thousands of young, able
bodied men descended upon the giant public
project, the government attempted to keep
them in a dry and “wholesome” community
nearby called Boulder City.
It didn’t work.
The population of Las Vegas, a place where
tired workers could drink, fraternize, and
frequent prostitutes to their monies’ content,
quadrupled in the first year of construction
of the Boulder Dam.
The influx of people brought immediate growth
in every avenue.
More saloons, bars, brothels, and hotels were
constructed.
Casino gambling was legalized by the Nevada
legislature in December 1931.
In order to keep up with the demand, more
city projects were begun, including paved
roads, a sewer system, and police stations
(to keep up with the increase in crime).
Tourists coming from all over the country
to witness the man-made marvel of Boulder
Dam being built also made sure they stopped
in Las Vegas.
From the beginning of the project in 1931
to 1939, the online Nevada Encyclopedia states
that $70 million more came into the city of
Las Vegas than was spent on the Hoover Dam.
The Las Vegas Club, Apache Hotel, and Northern
Club were the first hotels to get their casino
licenses.
They were all located on Fremont Street.
Construction slowed during World War II, but
in December 1946, on what is now known as
the Strip, the Flamingo opened.
This hotel and casino with its 105 rooms was
known as “The World’s Greatest Resort
Hotel.”
Named after a nickname of the girlfriend of
the majority owner (due to her long skinny
legs), this would be what every Vegas Hotel
& Casino would be modeled after going forward.
That majority owner was reputed Los Angeles
gangster and criminal Bugsy Siegel.
And so began, Las Vegas’s famous ties to
the mob.
The Las Vegas we now know today may be full
of buffets, glamorous live entertainment,
24/7 gambling, and poolside drinks, but the
beginnings of “Sin City” dates all the
way back to when there were no streets, neon
signs, or even railroads.
It was just a fertile plain located in
the Mojave Desert.